you know when you just do your
keyhole curriculum your aikido just
looks so
artificial it's like robotic but you
don't notice it because you don't know
all the other moves that you're supposed
to be able to do okay
so the the knife training is gonna help
bring fluidity
um to what we're doing in coordination
to what we're doing okay
so we we had the guy come in we're gonna
start
closer so that you get used to different
my okay so we start closer
and i'm going to keep that energy going
cut keep that energy going
so keep the energy going
don't start so far away i'm not going to
tell you again
okay let's go okay so he's going
and i i want a more dynamic
ipad my my ik adhesions can't just be on
it on this kind of stuff
okay so you just pull and
get that thing going get the fight
rotating
then not in this goofy stance
more natural stance more natural stance
so
uh let's take him out of the technique
okay
and we're gonna come over here and he's
gonna push on the technique
you see i i don't change anything i'm
embracing he's gonna push on this
technique
it doesn't change anything okay
i said you're like you see
push on the technique i got a braces
angle over here but
if i got him over here he goes i don't
have any
so more dynamic here
where you can kick have all your weapons
available
oh here the fight is rotating
if you need to you can use the cut to
assist
the grip
i told you not to do that
you can get the first cut
take it so first step here then mop
small movement okay
let's go so he goes pull and if i
tense the knife gets stuck so i gotta
get rid of my
my shoulder tension shoulder tension is
gone that
that tension gets in the way of your
adhesions too
so it's very relaxed very relaxed
okay same thing as you go
the reason the knife training is good is
that you
your subconscious will dominate that
hand
just like you'll dominate if you're uh
doing the technique you're gonna
dominate this hand
and your primary hand and you you're not
having this hand still going
you lose the yin hand in other okay
because your mind
is going i'll do one at a time but this
is not ikea
so as he's going this hand keeps going
it's not gonna stop till the knife gets
there and then goes
okay so this hand is still going
this hand is still going
okay try it again so just just as the
knife is
fluid in its movement my transitions are
fluid in the movement so
everything is just circles just inward
and outward spiral
so boom i'm here
notice the knife as i go for the arm
so my this stays there you see
don't come over here stays over there
he's going to try to come in so i come
in
and attack the shoulder clocks laterals
but then i want this shoulder down so it
gets in the way of the knife
so shoulder down project away
shoulders down by the elbow
don't control the elbows that he lands
underneath you
because he has a knife project away
okay try to understand the psychology
that you're battling
so when when you operate through your
ego tripartite
the young hand appears to be consistent
with your uh thread reactive reaction
cycle
right so that's why you lose the
the yin hand okay meaning like he's
pushing on me
it makes sense to my ego to push back on
him
okay so when you feel yourself when you
feel yourself going like you go this is
the young and this makes
sense and so psychologically
technically you lose the yin hand it
stops
okay so uh instead of it keeps going i'm
going to say things happening here
once you once you come like this you
start to lose the yin hand because you
smell your
ego ready to wham
and you focus on the young hand
so instead as you come around this
this hand keeps going i can start
lowering it
i don't lose it it won't stop or
disengage
both are this subconscious
threat cycle it's got to keep going
okay so drill it again okay so we're
going
and i'm going to come up to this
right here boom
see i don't let his arm bend
this ezekiel
this ego opens the hand
but we're going to learn it from another
position down here
boom okay
you're not going into the tama this time
here
[Music]
so you'll feel this energy like he's
coming into me right it's like the last
one he's coming into me
i'll feel the energy and i'll absorb it
this way
okay let's go so remember
at the start i said like when when all
you study is your
federation delivered
if you stay in a environment where
that's where everyone does you look
pretty coordinated but
from an athletic point of view you look
stiff
there's weird stances that no other
sport ever adopts like
like this one never you've never seen
this right
it's not even biomechanically healthy
for the inner knee here
you see why are you on a tightrope are
you in a fighter in a circus show
do you know do you know what i mean if i
was on a tightrope i'd probably walk
like that
so you think you're learning the
king on and therefore that you could do
it
but you you're not okay it's just so
confined in environment
that all the adaptability that would be
required to
transfer that technique into a live
environment
you don't have it so i'll show you what
we're having here so
we're let's say i'm going to do eq all
right ikea does not work like with his
armpit
do you see i need to know how to keep
his arm in such a position
that energy can be transferred from his
arm
to his center so when i go like this
energy is being
leaked through these hinges do you see
so i have to have his arm in such a
position
that it can go into his body as i move
his arm
okay
most of the time in kihon it just
happens because the culture the training
culture the uke they just do that right
so here we are now with this technique
and
this technique requires that i find a
way
of having that happen but from an
entirely different position
because what we're seeing you do now is
you're getting like this
you see and there's a lot of energy
leakage
from here in all these points of
articulation
shoulder elbow wrist
so as we go i have to be able
to control his body with the equal
no energy leakage i have to know how to
do that
without it always being like the keyhole
and it's a matter of feeling feeling
feeling i move if i feel he's he's
starting to leak
you see i'll move i move to keep that
feeling
okay so we're going boom
i'm moving okay try it again
so let's let's slow this one down okay
so he's going here
his energy's coming back to me maybe
maybe he's trying to stab he's going uh
one and two so the same thing won't
pull i go here this is what i affect his
elbow get the same angle cancellation in
the last
row by getting this shoulder lower than
the other one can't stand here because
this is not
jiu jitsu i'm fighting him so i yield
and i get it down there's my
cross lateral check on the other side of
his body i got my high check
on his legs and this is where i strip
so we'll slow it down just so you get
the feeling
move have a good base it's trap pull
your arm out
it's trapped it's not just here and i'm
not sliding it down
and it escapes out the bottom
it's trapped
[Music]
okay try it again keep that arm
without any energy leaking no let's have
a one and two
so one and two okay so we get an
another energy as we're coming around
this way okay
i'll feel that and i'm gonna pass it
okay so boom you'll feel it pass it
move don't get set in this stuff where
you're static
and don't lose the hands oh i still kept
the connection
whoa keep the connection move around it
boom
and we're going to keep the knife and
the throat because we're testing
ourselves on
on this young uh attraction
okay so i'm going to keep the
[Music]
nice and fluid and relaxed
let's okay so where are you going to see
the yin han
the yin han drop is that your uk is
sitting here
you're just sitting here and you're
going like this
oh if you keep the your hand the
original your hand going see he comes in
can we do that so i'm keeping the yin
hand go and you see
see how he keeps moving okay oh he keeps
moving
that's where you're gonna get your tilt
right it's just imagine
all that energy is going in there i get
the tilt and the same thing
here this this hand on the knife
is now the yin hand the in hand keeps
moving
doesn't just stay here and you go like
this okay
you punch them into the tilt you change
hands turn his head and the yin hand
keeps moving look he's going into the
tilt more
yin hang keeps moving
but we get this young and
keep that adhesion going
okay let's go okay so i'm we're not
gonna do the checking button i want you
to see what the yin hand is doing
okay no no you can do your part okay so
i'm going here
this keeps going see how you want to
stop but i
keep you going okay then you're pushing
in
and the same thing i don't leave you
there you feel go off
okay so you push it in and then i keep
that going you see how you step
so this hand is going keeps you going
you cut
in this hand keeps you going and there's
this tape
this is like when you do the graph right
it's it's
us all your your 10 knees that you see
but you're grab dependent you're young
dependent
but we're doing it on the enhancer same
thing
keep it going there's your technique we
just stick it in the other hand because
we can
uh in the second line after that we can
keep things going
we can stick other things in we're not
trapped in left right
we're outside dichotomy okay but you're
not here
okay let's go